[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
summer of chess comes to an end as 20
international grandmasters compete in
st. Louis u.s. chess champs calm
presents the third annual fall chess
classic hello and welcome back to our
coverage of the 2019 fall chess classic
joining me here today for our round four
coverage is the wonderful a former US
Champion two-time actually a grandmaster
Patrick wolf hi nice pleasure to have
you with us Patrick
thank you I'm glad you can make it out
to do some commentary over these
exciting games yes fun some good games
here
yeah and interesting tournament
situation as well
in fact the round actually is back to
its normal time today yesterday they got
started an hour earlier but as always
our show starts at 3:30 p.m. every day
up until the final round and why don't
we take a look at where we stand in this
tournament with the a group standings
the seve derp I li is the man of the
hour so far winning his round three game
putting him at an astounding two and a
half out of three chasing close behind
though our Darrow's roots and Alexander
Linderman just a half point out of first
place and there are a myriad of players
at one and a half all with excellent
chances to make a bid for this first
place spot and over in the B group we
have Jackson buyuk with an incredible
three out of three scores so far we'll
see today if he can make it an
unbelievable four out of four
but solidly in first place and then we
actually also have a player in clear
second with yasser Quesada Perez with
two and a half out of three and then
following him is Steven Zurich with two
points so three players actually all in
the clear first second and third spots
and why don't we take a look at the
format for this tournament see what the
players are playing there of course 210
player round robins and the time control
for each game is 90 minutes for the
first 40 moves with 30 minutes added on
for the remainder of the game after move
40 there's also a 30-second increment
from move
if you're a fan of the World Cup going
on right now this is actually the exact
same time control that they're playing
in that event there's also a draw rule
in effects where players are not allowed
to offer each other a draw until blacks
thirtieth move but I will keep the games
going for as long as possible for you
guys you guys as always are welcome to
join us and join the show on YouTube
we're keeping an eye on the chat good to
see you all in there Akash John Doe
Frode Chan and end others as well thank
you all for joining the show if you have
any questions for us any comments we
will be glad to take a look at that and
try to answer those to the best we can
you can also join us on Twitter using
the hashtag fall chess classic and if
you want to watch the games for yourself
you can always see them live on us chess
champs calm well without further ado why
don't we take a look at the pairings for
today in Group A we have Ray Robson
paired against Ilyas myrin Alex a pataga
taking on Alexander Lenderman the Battle
of the Alex's Front Melkonyan taking on
Hugh Orton van forest olexander bortnik
playing Vysya dura bali the group a
leader at the moment and then our key
matchup of the day is actually between
st. Louis native Varro Cobian and Doris
weirds one of those chasing players in
the second place this is not the first
time these players have played in st.
Louis actually meeting a couple years
ago in the 2017 spring chess classic and
that's an event where var actually won
that game and won the tournament
outright so this will be an interesting
rematch see what daro can can pull off
against bar here well Patrick what do
you think in this game where do we stand
okay so obviously it's it's blacks move
the bishop on g5 is attacked so let's
see if I can use my clever devices here
nope that didn't work ah there we are
okay so the bishop here on g5 is
attacked by the pawn on f6 the bishop is
going to have to move presumably it will
move I'm sorry I think I said it was
black stone it's White's turn so the the
bishop will have to move probably either
III or D to a computer right now thinks
that the best
move it is for the bishop to come here
to e3 so if we make that move we see
that you know the bishop is protecting
the pawn on d4 and white is generally
well centralized but regardless of where
white decides to move the bishop whether
the e3 or d2 I'd say this is a very very
pleasant position for white these two
pawns here again let me see if I can
highlight these just give quite a very
nice central position controlling these
critical squares here black has
reasonably placed pieces but a little
bit passive not really doing anything
yet very strong center fairway there's
tungsten a common source of counter play
for a black is trying to get this night
into c4 and it looks like white really
has that Square controlled pretty well
here that's correct and it's good that
you point that out so this night here on
on a5 doesn't really have any active
prospects right now in fact I say it's
best prospects would be in fact for the
night to come back here to the c6 square
but doing that within block this Bishop
on b7 we're all told and this bishop
here on g7 of course quite passive at
the moment the way for black to try to
activate this bishop would be to push
this pawn to f5 that would weaken the
squares around blacks King even more
meanwhile White's King very secure every
one of White's pieces well centralized
active it's just a very easy position
for white to play and I should point out
the computer agrees because even though
material is equal the computer actually
thinks white has an advantage of a full
pawn in this position and it seems
difficult here right black would love to
challenge White's Center in some way but
both e5 and f5 which would be the main
ways to do that have serious drawbacks
if black were to play something like e 5
would white just respond with with d5
kind of just cutting off the bishop and
really slide binding that night well
there be two ways there would be my
instinct well there were two ways to go
so if we can imagine this position here
which is the bishop moves to e3 and
black plays in five
yes white could push the pawn to d5 but
actually stronger is to take this pawn
on e5 because after black takes back you
see that whites blacks
he was extremely exposed and what the
computer actually likes very much is
this move Bishop d2 attacking the knight
on a5 with the idea that after you take
this knight and black takes back this
bishop here can move to c4 check and now
the king is in imminent danger so I
don't expect that to happen
interesting retreating moves to make
these threats for white so it looks like
was knight c6 actually played then yes
so so a Cobian played the boo the bishop
to d2 when they were passive in the
Bishop III computer does not like it as
much I tend to agree black has responded
immediately by moving the knight to c6
trying to activate it attacking this
pawn and we see that drawback is if the
bishop were here on this e3 square then
this pawn on d4 would already be
defended but it's not and now the pawn
on d4 something needs to be done the
computer suggests two moves one move is
Queen to e3 and the other move is Bishop
to c3 both are probably equally good
they're fine I'd say that white still
has a perfectly good position certainly
if you gave him the choice of which side
to play I'd take white in a heartbeat
yeah but I think Black has helped
himself just a little bit over these
last two moves because now white needs
to spend a move moving somehow taking
care of this bond and that gives black a
little more time right and so we
actually see Queen III from virus so his
idea was to actually keep that keep that
Square for the Queen Yeah right
and so bar has a very pleasant position
very poised but how does he make any
progress here do you break in the center
eventually with a move like a 5 or d5
for white or do you just kind of play on
the Queen side with like a 4 a 5
actually what I would say is in a
position like this you don't really need
to make any progress right now this is
one of the things that makes this
position so Pleasant right now for white
so difficult for black that is white can
simply take his time and probe on
different sides of the of the board he
can maybe try moving this night out here
to h4 at some point to tickle this pawn
on g6 movement maybe move this rook to
b5 thinking about coming over at some
point maybe move the Bishop to c4 at
some point trying to
this week pawn on e6 there's lots of
different things just Y can do just
playing with the pieces yes but just
playing and and waiting because if black
does anything to misplace a piece or
create a more weaknesses with one of the
pawns that may open up an opportunity
for black I mean what block is gonna
have to stay vigilant all the time
absolutely so things not looking so good
for Daario here well of course one of
the two players just a half-point
Poseidon massif are behind the sieve
Dhirubhai Dhirubhai Lee excuse me in in
the group a well well that game
continues on why don't we take a look at
the B group pairings see where we stand
there Steven zerk is paired against
Victor mihailovski Aman Hamilton is
playing Dennis Gaede Rick Alexander fear
is playing a tournament second place
player in the B group yessir Quesada
Perez abetik Gregorian is playing a
rhombic Obion and then in our key
matchup of the day we have Manuel
petrosyan actually the highest rate of
player in the B group playing against
the B group leader Jack Shambu lyac who
has been unstoppable thus far winning
all three of his games we see the
players there and in a pretty
interesting position actually a lot of
progress has been made since I last took
a look at this game what's going on
well it is a very interesting position
what I would say is so the computer
thinks objectively this is equal and I
agree with the computer you know look it
certainly looks to me like this is
objectively equal black now has a
fundamental choice to make does black
take this pawn with the pawn like this
which creates one type of pawn structure
obviously with this strong past pump at
the same time isolated so it can be a
source of strength but also potential
weakness or does black take the pawn
with the Queen preserving the pawn
structure but on the other hand it's not
clear exactly what this Queen is doing
out here and might actually just have to
retreat and give white the opportunity
to bring his pieces into play with tempo
right big choice to make here oh there's
a third option there I can move the
knight to f6 here but this the computer
really doesn't like so much for very
simple reason this Queen can move to a
square that loads
a potential discovered check here on a
to write and this the problem here is
however blocks going to take this pong
White's going to be able to move the
night to d4 next and now so let's say
let's say you actually make a move let's
say Knight takes takes yeah so after
Knight takes actually white can move the
knight here to d4 but can also move the
knight here to d2 with discovered Chuck
and in fact this is what the computer
thinks is even stronger and after King
h8 Knight takes Knight now suddenly it's
a bit of an awkward position for block
yeah you can feel the weakness of the
black king after having pushed the
blocking and importantly the weakness of
the black pawn right so for example
after pawn takes you could play a move
like Queen c2 or Queen c4 tickling this
pawn which is which really becomes a
weakness so I would say it's a very
imbalance position it's probably
objectively equal but stand Bullock has
been very successful in this tournament
so far obviously so just because the
position is objectively equal since it
is so imbalanced especially if block
does play this move F takes e4 which the
computer clearly thinks is best and so I
expect he will play right a lot of
complications very uncertain position I
think sort of the real game is yet to
come
yeah Jack definitely has not been one to
shy away from complications this
tournament he's really navigated towards
them and navigated through them quite
well he's been a surprise or an
incredibly accurate calculator yes so
far which I guess isn't surprising but
maybe surprising to his opponents how
well he's really understanding these
these tactics and these positions so
with that in mind I guess we can we can
head anywhere Patrick what games look
interesting to you well let me let me
scroll up there's a game I'd like to
point out here this is epitaphs versus
Alexander Lenderman now this is this is
a very very interesting position because
right now the computer thinks actually
that the game is nearly equal which is
pretty amazing because just a couple of
moves ago I'm just gonna clip back a
couple of moves the computer thought
actually that the position was very very
good for blacks so what the computer was
recommending here instead of Bishop
takes Knight which is the move that
lunderman play right black could have
played this move here pawn to f4 and
this really would have presented a
fundamental choice for white if white
moves the bishop let's say white moves
the bishop here to e1 and this is
allowing the pin on the B file right
exactly so now Bishop takes Knight Queen
takes bishop no ask you even yet a
skewer yeah so no bueno so instead of
this the computer was suggesting Knight
a seven but black has a trick well I can
move the bishop to a four this Bishop
here still being attacked
Bishop moves here let's say two from the
c3 pawn and now rook a eight and now it
turns out there's no good square there's
no good way to defend this Knight
yes again the same tactic exists exactly
exactly
so that's what the computer expected was
going to happen but instead what
happened I'll just move back here so in
this position after Knight takes d5
Lenderman simply took the took the knife
back so what's the difference after a
queen takes b5 does not like not still
have f4
with he doesn't have that for which he
might play but let's let's cover a key
tactic first sure because at the moment
it looks like Knight takes c3 of course
with fork the Queen in the rook but it's
possible that Lenderman overlooked that
White has this move Queen b4 which moves
the Queen off the attacking square but
because it's hitting the Queen on e7 of
course black can't take the rook and if
black takes the Queen rook takes Queen
and now even this pawn is doubly
attacked by the rook and the bishop so
suddenly black white has excuse me black
has no advantage
whatsoever so maybe he overlooked this
maybe not we'll have to ask him
afterwards after after Bishop takes
Queen takes so why doesn't the same
tactic work as my question with f4 with
the idea of playing rook b8 next right
so black plays f4 the key point is y can
move the bishop to this square age for
very fancy right fun so now I would
expect Queen takes Bishop yeah
Queen takes Knight right so this is a
key point so you would expect a black
did you [ __ ] yeah it's just to cut off
this bishop
so now after pawn to g5 White has this
move rook to e1 interesting so and this
now threatens Queen takes Knight ah ah
interesting let's actually go to the
game because in fact what has happened
is Knight takes pawn queen before Queen
takes Queen obviously white will play
rook takes Queen and I have to say here
this is to me this is really a stunning
turn of events and it well yeah that's
not missing something really fundamental
very tricky tactics there after in that
f4 line yeah I'm willing to bet that's
what Alex was missing is this Bishop h4
and then g5 and then rook e1 all these
weird moves from white that don't
necessarily save his pieces but make
counter threats okay I would say I think
you're right but I would say that's
really a shame for Lindemann because
yeah you're not very nice but just a few
moves ago in even here black didn't have
to play the Queen to e7 there were other
ways to play but a 27 is a fine move if
you see these tactics right but after
missing this and rook takes Knight e3
well I mean I would expect this to be a
draw I'd say that Lenderman
has really missed quite an opportunity
he really had a very good position yeah
he could have been banking on this one
as
full point and now it looks like it's
just gonna be a draw yeah I'm sure he's
quite disappointed that that was the
type of position that you know feels
very very nice to play yeah all your
pieces are better White's pieces are
disjointed and then somehow he kind of
miraculously seems to escape yeah that's
that's why you know this accurate
calculation is so important these days
yep
so we're expecting a draw here now which
is a pretty huge for the tournament
because Alex was joining daro with the
players with two out of three in the
eighth group and so those are the two
main players that could really catch the
seat Dhirubhai Lee and both of them not
really looking like they're gonna get it
done today so let's take a look at the
Derby dirt Dhirubhai Lee yeah I believe
so ah so this is a very interesting
position that we have here
extremely imbalance now here this is
interesting this is another case where
the computer thinks that this position
is equal and that's probably true but I
would say that it's equal with with the
caveat that whichever player is playing
better is likely to win because what we
have here is an extremely imbalance
position white has the two bishops which
right now may not look like much but get
to an endgame
those two bishops could be everything
yeah we've seen them come to life before
earlier in this tournament and also
black has a strong center to be sure but
this d5 pawn here both a strength and a
weakness because white is attacking it
with the bishop only to then I don't see
three the Queen on g2 and in particular
hitting that rook on e6 but on the other
hand black does have more space oh I
should have one more thing definitely
needs to be pointed out here which is we
do have a battery here and of course
this knight on g6 is blocking it but if
that Knight would it go away boom that
pawn on g7 would go with Czech and
blacks King would be very very much in
trouble so there's all of that going on
that points in White's favor but what
points in blacks favor more space very
active pieces and White's King could be
quite exposed here too especially since
we do have this bishop here which right
now is asleep but you know one day that
pawn could
from E 5 to e4 not at all hard to
imagine an attack taking place here so I
guess the point I'm making is right now
the computer doesn't see any and neither
do I by the way right see any
particularly good way for white to break
through the main line is Bishop e3 work
a5 Bishop g5 it is kind of poking at
those that's what a poking around now
that this should be 7 so it's like blah
blah blah nothing's really happening but
maybe at some point something will
happen this is this is certainly not a
sleeper game this is the same word under
this it could explode at some point and
given his incredible form this
tournament one to wash could could very
well be a decisive game ya have to say
I'm inclined to actually favor the the
black pieces here white does have this
bishop pair that they got become very
very dangerous later on but it seems
like black is the one kind of making the
threats here I agree I think if you if
you force me to take one side I would
take the black side versus voice' the
other thing worth point out is the time
white only has 15 and a half minutes or
so left block has a little bit more than
19 minutes it's like if white thinks
several more minutes you know we're only
on move 25 I guess to make the move 26
here the LOB moves left to make in a
position that could get very complicated
yeah what could happen
it feels like if white slips up just one
time then this move like efore or even a
like Knight age 5 to f4 socially is
really going to crush White's position
if he if he isn't really on the lookout
for these types of things yeah so things
are looking up for the sieve Dhirubhai
lee even if he only draws this game he
would maintain his clear first position
as we're expecting those two chasers
they're not actually doing a so great in
this round in lunderman and let's take a
quick look at a game between two good
grandmasters where it does look like one
side is is winning and then I'd like to
go back to a game we looked at earlier
so just this game quickly Robson versus
miron and Ray has an extra pawn this
pawn on c3 is it's it's his turn to move
now he is a little short on time he
doesn't have that many moves to make
this will be moved 32 but so that the
line that the computer favors which
makes all the intuitive sense in the
world is to take this rook here now if
black were to take with the rook of
course this pawn on d6 would draw right
so instead of doing that
well maybe even take with the Knights
about in any way case instead of doing
that Queen takes and now this Knight
gets to come out here and come to this
very powerful square c6 yeah this looks
devastating so what we have here is
White has active pieces as Queen on our
six in particular right the King's a
little bit drafty this Knight working
its way to a very strong square Hey and
on top of that an extra pawn so what
more can you ask for it looks like a
very pleasant position for white we'll
have to walk to check in a little bit
later but this one I would lay some some
money on that Robson's likely to win ya
race had a bit of an up-and-down
tournament he drew his first game very
quickly and then actually lost in round
two but he managed to bounce back in
round three with the win and things are
looking good for him here and this would
this would put him into probably second
place if a Letterman and ro can't win
their games too so that's so that's a
key game to watch now let's come back to
this a Cobian Suarez game and remember
we were talking a few minutes ago about
how white doesn't really have to do
anything yeah and just sort of probe
poke probe poke wait for black to do
something well Bly has done something
push some pieces around it like what's
committed yeah so let's go back a couple
of moves when we last checked in we were
here and all of a sudden hey black
pushed upon the g5 so now white says
okay now I know where the weakness is
now blacks gonna try to move his knight
around to f8 + g6
so here we are up - up to where we are
in the game I would have to say I'm not
super impressed with the idea of moving
the Knight to g6 because even once this
Knight comes to g6 White's gonna be able
so let's just once this Knight comes to
g6 here white will be able to push the
pawn to g3 yeah I think this is key
Square this is the point of blacks play
though he wants to provoke white into
playing g3 and then this Bishop on b7
starts to look a little bit more
threatening you can definitely imagine
the what the black king or queen coming
to c6 and then some tactics happening
along this diagonal yeah maybe you could
imagine that but what I can imagine is
this pawn on e6 is very weak these
squares around the King very weak some
kind of advance here could easily happen
open up blacks King I would be very very
afraid to have blacks position here the
computer thinks white has the advantage
of the pawn and a half I tend to agree
with it and again white didn't have to
do anything all white did was put his
pieces on good squares waited and I know
I have experiences it's so painful to
try to defend these positions you want
to do something active but once you do
something active you've created more
weaknesses and actually opened up the
Avenue of attack for white
understandable but so we'll have to see
what happens
oh by the way another thing have to
mention time here so here we are
it is move 27 white to make his 27th
move excuse me black to make his 27th
move white has dropped the bishop back
here to b3 black now has less than 5
minutes
so once the game opens up the lines to
the king are exposed Black's gonna have
precious little time to figure out what
the right moves are absolutely I think
this is a place to look for some for
some bloodshed yeah as long as the game
hasn't opened up black always has to be
calculating these lines where white
could open up up the game and that is
that's where all this time is
really going yes and so this is
definitely going to be a struggle for
door oh here okay for some reason the
clocks been adjusted looks like it's six
and a half as opposed to four and a half
so I guess we don't have quite that time
but still not a lot of time one way or
the other not a lot of time nope now
it's back to four a half well at any
rate I don't know what's happening but I
can tell you black doesn't have a lot of
time there is still a lot of weaknesses
around blacks King I would look for this
to open up I think this is gonna be a
very exciting game over the next 15-20
minutes to check in on so let's uh
unless you have an idea of where you'd
like to go next I was I was just gonna
say judging by the the body language
there daro seems to be very very
stressed he's hunched over the board
deep in calculation I'm sure why don't
we check out what's going on in the B
group a little bit yes has any progress
been made in our key matchup between
Petrosyan and Jackson Billy a good
question and the answer so far is not so
much okay you know it's it's still an
equal looking position computer thinks
this is equal I would certainly tend to
agree so just just to go back and show
what happened here very simple black
played pawn takes pawn white moves the
bishop to d4 and now it's blacks turn to
move yeah this Bishop d4 idea seems
interesting from light that dark screw
bishop for black is a very important
defender yeah in positions like this yes
especially with the F pawn gun this
black king is looking quite airy to me
yes I think this would be a huge source
of concern for me if I were at the play
with the black pieces well I wouldn't
call it a huge source of concern I don't
think blacks King is in terrible danger
you could imagine a scenario where it's
in danger okay but I definitely agree
through this move Bishop d4 makes all
the sense in the world so there's a very
useful rule of thumb it's very simple
the rule of thumb is trade off your
opponent's piece if it's more active
than yours right pretty straightforward
right so if we look here blacks Bishop
very active not hitting anything but
very active the c3 square here for
example could easily be something to to
watch out for a lot of danger so white
very sensibly wants to trade it off and
oh hey by the way opens up to c5 square
the night - jump - yeah and very
important to mention here it might look
like III is a winning tactic for black
but Y could actually just capture that
pawn I believe it because rook on d7 is
unfortunately placed that's exactly
right that's exactly right so if we if
we want to move forward on the three y
can go Bishop takes and then let's just
say Knight takes Queen takes excuse and
then simplest here it's just a block to
take the rook right away at the end of
the day why it's gonna be up to pawn why
it's gonna be up upon I think it would
be very difficult for white to win this
position because blacks have a lot of
activity there's young Bishop is Gil if
you gave me a choice I don't have white
of course that goes on no reason to go
here and instead actually symbolic
played a very sensible move move in the
rook to d8 if I was making some of these
threats perhaps making some threats just
bringing the work into the center
supporting the knight on d5 there's sort
of a coiled spring effect here we don't
know exactly what's going to happen but
something could at some point and you
know again that we have a player who's
had tremendous success so far he's in
very good form in this tournament and so
he's keeping the tension he's keeping
sort of maximum flexibility for
something to happen right the computer
might look at this and say oh I think
this is a 1/10 of a pawn less good of a
minute than what I thought the best move
was right but the human might look at
this and say look I'm keeping all of my
chances and I think I'm gonna be better
at exploiting any messiness that occurs
on the board versus my opponent yeah so
I like this and and just looking at some
natural moves here for why I'd be
tempted to play something like Knight c5
absolutely and try to kick around this
this black rook and organize my pieces
to work against this yes well this is
the computers first choice and I
certainly agree I think 95 makes a lot
of sense now I want to follow this up
take off that dark squared Bishop on g7
and play something like rook e1 and just
attack this pawn well I think there's a
lot of things that could happen here
black could decide to push the pawn
black could simply decide to move the
rook over I think basically this is a
great big tea
don't know what's going to happen and
that's the point the point is we still
have this maximum tension on in the
position now mr. Bullock of course and
Stan Bullock has half the time as
petrosyan so that's something to be
aware of and 14 moves to make if so you
know a lots lot could happen I mean you
could be an excellent form but if you
have no time left
even excellent form is gonna melt in the
form of time pressure books men will
just chose to take off this Bishop on g7
immediately it looks like interesting
interesting so taking that Bishop on g7
and now the computer likes pushing this
pawn on e3 before taking the bishop on
g7 I wonder what Justin Bullock's going
to do understandable
what's this Queen after e3 I think the
Queen is forced to e2 unless I'm missing
something and there's these threats of
Knight c3 if if white isn't very careful
yeah well the Queen can actually also go
to d4 but this is exactly the sort of
thing that
Petrosyan is going to have to think
about remember maximum flexibility
maximum messiness maximum potential for
the person with the most that the
strongest form to take advantage of
whatever may occur if Queen d4 seems
like a crazy move to me so III Queen D
for e2 and then I guess rook f8 it's the
idea what's going on yeah well we're
cafe does the idea and so some gears are
spinning here right now believe it or
not the computer actually likes Queen c2
but Queen e2 is the favorite move which
i think makes a lot of sense
and then there's virtually no difference
between rook takes or King takes and
we'll just have to see if we get to this
position very difficult at this point to
sort of score what's going on like the
computer just coolly thinks it's about
equal no big deal yeah I think a human
being looks at this and says holy cow
very double-edged super-powerful pawn
here on e3 I can't let this thing push
any anymore on the other hand if I can
just get to an endgame
I have this very nice structure my
knight comes to c5 controls everything
this pawn on it
they end up being weak let's see see
what happened understandable
understandable to me that the computer
is giving equal here because if black
really tries to push too hard tries to
you know get these rooks into White's
position he's going to be leaving behind
his King yep and so he's going to need
these major pieces on the back couple of
ranks to defend some squares yep and
that's gonna make it slightly more
difficult by the way this is the
position on the game board so it is now
up and Timberlake has taken with the
king and now petrosyan will have to
decide what he wants to do computer
favors 95 which certainly makes sense as
a move but if you play 95 after rook e7
okay now block now why does to play
another move and another move still not
very cool what what the right moves are
here a lot of tension in this position
it actually looks like a Mon Hamilton is
running into some trouble in his game if
you're interested in taking a look at
that yeah absolutely hang on a second
let me ah here we go alright
we've loaded this up and my that's quite
a strong pawn structure white has yeah
it's a very interesting position here
and Mon actually down to just 35 seconds
on his clock with nine more moves to
make whole week very difficult situation
to be in very very difficult well see
Dennis actually moving quite fast I
don't know if I actually agree with this
strategy here it seems like he's playing
against Amon's clock but maybe now is
the time to be planning for some
accurate moves what moves are happening
very quickly so now this this rook is
attacked but interestingly well White
has to choose whether he should move the
rook or maybe play Bishop d5 to attack
the Queen first in either case it's a
difficult position because the problem
is this rook is gonna run out of squares
along this rank right and once it does
so for example if route d4 Bishop c5
attacking the rook and then this pawn on
f4 is going to be in trouble without the
rook defending it here yeah can I gain a
tempo with York d5 and try to defend it
some other way
for example rook d4 Bishop c5 rook d5
yeah but the problem is this turns out
to be quite catastrophic Oh interesting
it's worth the bishop yeah to break this
up because where's your strong pawn
something now exactly where yeah it's
almost a ton now show me your own pawn
center and I mean while White's Knights
are in terrible shape and whites King is
very weak meanwhile we should point out
seconds are tick
so he moved the Bishop of d5 black moves
immediately to FA he's got six more
moves to make and very difficult even to
figure out what his next move here is
going to be this looks famous though
things are very very dodgy to me but
yeah once again Dennis moving with
lightning speed doesn't make sense
bishops he thought he should play
immediately because it's clearly the
right move okay
and now White has to decide White has a
difficult choice does he move the rook
does he protect the work with the Queen
if it protects with the work with the
Queen where does he move the Queen these
are very very difficult decisions to
make and he's only got seconds to do it
yeah and it looks like he hasn't made a
decision that rook does stay on d4 and
he plays Queen d2 so a very very
interesting imbalance here and now that
it's down the computer actually thinks
that rook takes d 6e takes d6 and Queen
66 is completely devastated
oh yes an absolutely completely lost
everything falling apart so now would be
a good time to get this plane down yes
this would be an excellent moment for
him to take some time and and consider
his options yeah in that line it looks
like white ends up in some just lost end
game with two Knights against two very
powerful bishops yeah and just past a
pawn to boot yeah so it looks like he is
he is taking some time to think so let's
let's play this out a little bit takes
takes Queen takes and the only move I
could find was Bishop f7 but then a
black would simply take on d4 with them
yeah the Bishop f7 doesn't work because
this work is defended by the bishop so
in fact you might as well just pass you
might as well just move the Queen and
it's even not best to take but according
to a computer but let's play this out a
little bit here and the computer thinks
that you can actually torture white a
little bit more with but that's fine
taking on d4 is good enough thank you
sir and after Queen takes and Queen d7
and the problem you run into is this
[ __ ] like you're just gonna push this
pawn and at some point or you can you're
threatening Bishop f7 at some point
white is gonna have to do something to
allow you to give this work up for the
bishop so you can play Knight f1 so
here's one line yeah I might try like 93
there for example yeah
yes maybe instead of a night off one
just just 93 immediately it would be my
guess
so instead if you play 93 immediately
and there's those rook takes night but
yeah you can play Bishop f7 which
actually is probably even stronger but
never mind
it takes night is plenty good enough
right extra pawn
there's no checkmate it was something
very easy win over here on the Queen
side I was hoping to play something like
f5 and shake something loose but I guess
it's just not working but on f5 you can
simply play Bishop f7 yeah I wanted
Queen e7 I wanted to try to make some
threats against this King yeah but but
it's Lots got everything under control
right he always has a h6 and king h7 for
shelter there yeah there's no no
problems there yeah and this by the way
he's being very smart yeah and we
actually have some breaking news
lunderman has drawn his game against a
pataga
so he moves to two and a half out of
four
once again following the leader of a
sieve Dhirubhai lee yeah and it's a
shame for London and I have to think
that he's gonna be quite unhappy with
himself this afternoon this evening with
that because he missed a very good
opportunity so just as we watch here I
think actually speaking to point a
minute or two ago I would say that the
way that Dennis has handled the clock
against Hamilton by in the terrible time
pressure has been very good when he knew
what moves he wanted to play he played
them quickly now he knows he has a
critical moment where he's contemplating
how to really fundamentally shift the
position he's gonna take his time he's
gonna figure out what he wants to do and
then he's not gonna give Hamilton any
time to think about any sort of choices
along the way and very as long as he
knows exactly what move he wants to play
professional stuff from Dennis let's see
where else can we jump to then we
haven't taken a look at Stephens York's
game against Victor mihailovski
that one however is not looking so
interesting is it they seem to have
fizzled out into a major piece endgame
yeah I'm not pull it up here no I'd say
I mean I mean it's a position your
concern
he played computer slightly prefers
black and I agree I would certainly
rather have the black position in the
white position here
you know black could certainly try to
squeeze whites um it wouldn't shock me
if we're coming back to this at a later
point and I'm trying to suss out what
winning chances Black has but overall
I'd say this looks like it should
probably be a draw with with solid play
I don't know I was just expecting
something like Queen d4 from white and
well it's blacks turn oh sorry blacks
turn I guess that does make some
difference but how do you make any
threats or how do you have you tighten
the screws a little bit yeah Ocean Drive
wait let's just play out what the
computer slightly prefers is the main
line for black Queen e4 oh I would be
very tempted to take that Queen
but you know it's an interesting
question whether you want to take this
Queen I'll tell you why because after
Queen takes rook takes and guess I'm
getting forced into some passivity after
something yes c4 yes so the big problem
that white has in this position is white
doesn't have any good way to activate
his rook without allowing black to take
this pawn on c3 and if you take this
pawn on c3 now suddenly you've got to
connect it passes very dangerous that's
pretty dangerous maybe the second game
isn't something I can go for yeah this
is exactly the move that Victor's played
he has played Queen e4 and something I
was relying on is as the ability to
trade into a rook endgame they'll just
be drawn but this pawn structure it
really is I guess not so good for white
yeah this is interesting I mean I would
say the biggest drawback I would say
with blocks position is simply that his
King there's a little bit exposed you
could imagine this becoming a problem
however right now black is in the
driver's seat because these two pawns
here these a3 and C three pawns are
quite weak and in particular there are a
lot of opportunities white may have to
try to trade one of these pawns but you
can never really trade this the C pawn
for this a pond here
so just two you can never really engage
in that trade because these two
connected passed pawns here are just
gonna be too powerful for block in the
endgame right so I think what you've got
is a situation where white is forced to
adopt passive placement of pieces now
that again the computer is churning away
the computer is not too worried because
basically what the computer says is I'm
looking out umpteen moves I don't really
see how you can force anything I'm just
gonna sit on my squares here and this
ought to be a draw yeah it's probably
true but when humans are playing humans
a position like this something like this
can often be quite unpleasant now
against that is a tiny consideration
black does have less than two minutes
according to my clock here but just 5
moves to make and just 5 moves to be so
you got to make those moves I make those
moves they shouldn't be too hard to make
I agree we've gotta make those moves oh
yeah I don't know I can imagine like
playing King at Jay Kingi a king a Jay
King g8 and why it really isn't isn't
going to be doing much in my opinion
maybe maybe we'll stop obviously that's
not what Blackwood wanted right well
the8 for example would have been a
mistake because after King H a queen h5
check and then all of a sudden you know
not so clear anymore
yeah all I meant to say was uh but white
white isn't really going to be making
too many threats if like just kind of
sits on the position well so so black
has offered the trade of Queens and and
by our o'clock here it looks like
there's two minutes left
well this is slightly more confusing to
me now no I would now get yes is this
rook b6 option that's exactly right so
let's go back and explain this to the
viewers so before this was not so good
because there was no way that black that
white could stop block from moving the
rook to this square and on the c-4
square the rook would attack this pawn
on c3 and defend that pawn on c6 at the
same time that was a really important
point but now in this position in the
game
the computer actually thinks this is
completely equal and I'll explain why
after takes and takes now after it'd be
six now black can play a move like
whoopsie too but hey you know what this
is not the same thing at all yes you're
gonna get the pawn back by pushing this
pawn to d4
well like please c4 you can and pawn to
d3 and let me put it this way this is
white isn't White's in no danger of
winning this position because White's
King is really passive here this pawn on
d3 is very is very strong but if we just
spool this out and just take my word for
this for a few minutes the computer
strangely actually likes to move f3
let's not debate it let's just assume
this is a good enough move okay what
we're gonna get is this kind of position
right yeah f3 maybe allowing the King to
come through yes yes yes here here here
here here and this the computer thinks
and I concur
basically ought to be a draw right so
I'm at this level I think they know how
to draw this one so this I you know
going back to what we were talking about
a couple of minutes ago about the clock
you know just because you're probably
not in danger of losing doesn't mean
you're gonna press the position if he
had had an extra 10 minutes I'm quite
sure he would have found a much more
accurate way right keep turning the
screws and the computer might think hey
it's only a difference of three tenths
of a pawn no big deal but from a human's
perspective actually black had a very
pleasant position where he could really
try to push and squeeze and instead what
we're probably gonna have happen is
going to trade down into an endgame
that's just gonna Peter out to a draw
yeah I tend to agree
one interesting game we have not taken a
look at yet is the game of yet yes sir
Quesada Perez who was actually in second
place in the B group and he seems to be
putting on some pressure as well with
the black pieces in an endgame yeah this
was one that alone I was I was following
this a little while ago and I didn't
actually think much was happening
but yes I completely concur this has
become unpleasant for for white so we
have an act we have a passive Bishop
here and White's King not really doing
anything here contrast that to Black's
Knight really you know it's not
completely dominating this Bishop yeah
usually but the roles are reversed
across yeah I mean the bishop does this
have cancel to poke its poke its nose
out here but still the knight on d4
radiates a lot of power and now and also
notice this very centralized King course
on d5 now is it enough to win my guess
is probably not
I don't you know there's sort of the
rule of two weaknesses and really white
only has one weakness here there isn't
another weakness in in White's position
white does seem to have everything kind
of under control at this point it's not
clear to me how black presses but I
would certainly rather have black than
white and clearly there are some
practical chances here just one plan I
might come up with is can I put my rook
on b4 and then play the move C for
trying to make this a for pawn look very
very weak yes certainly you can I think
in plausible scenarios where that might
happen this pawn on e4 is probably going
to end up being weak remember you know
you can move your rook over but why it's
not necessarily just gonna stand still
so yeah let's let's try it I play this
out a little bit here here you know I'll
play rook before here here and yeah I
want to break through a C for me but now
if you break through with c4 the
computer actually doesn't like this at
all takes takes takes takes here you
know what you kind of already have
solved my problem I'm quickly coming to
this square here with the King you move
the knight the bishops gonna poke out I
would I would actually argue quite
strongly that this position offers black
less chances by far than the game
position we have right now okay and it's
um
black where to play a knife me maybe
three or ninety six in that position and
then bring that night to see five I'm
defending my epon I'm also threatening
the a pond okay so let's just go one
more time sorry so well he did play rook
f6 actually so it's a little bit of a
moot point but let's play it out
so let's say let's say me go here here
here here here
eggs cakes takes takes here you want to
play this move now I'm gonna play this
move you want to play let's see in 8c 5
was my guess move and now this move okay
and I would have thought that training
in month the a pawn for the e pawn would
be very very favorable for me in fact in
fact it's actually we think it's
actually a draw here okay takes takes
takes takes f4 yeah so what white is in
time today takes here here and watching
time I believe it I believe it so at any
rate I think Black has played not just
correctly but also practically keeping
the tension no need to force anything
yeah this is white so so black played
this move here work f6 white played this
move here Bishop and h5 the game
continues again the computer likes
blacks position a little bit right I
don't think it's huge but it's something
and it's annoying I certainly would
rather be playing black fish in White's
position primarily because you have the
super active King versus this you know
pretty passive King blacks work here
more active than whites work here I
think it's probably draw with good play
but and also something happening you
know where it's just uncomfortable for
white it's uncomfortable you have to
keep an eye on this beep on you have to
keep an eye on this rook on f6
pressuring the the f2 pawn as well and
it's knight on d4 has a few places that
it can go to it's just I don't know it
just doesn't feel feel comfortable to me
to be played I agree with it it's not a
comfortable position for white well it's
been a while since we checked in on the
a group
how is var do and I actually direct your
attention Denis's game because you
remember you remember this yes so he did
make his decision and yes I'm this
richtek let's go back and show so
remember remember we had this position
and then suddenly Denis sat and thought
because hey there was something to think
about he saw for a while thought before
taking the the rook right and we were
talking about route 66 immediately but
he chose instead to take on d4 at first
he did choose to take first oops excuse
me about this excuse me is I'm
auto-updating but right we actually want
to go through this step-by-step so you
can see so I think you have to refresh
the board to to make a stop okay it so
let's let's do that thank you
so here we are this is when we last
tuned in and right after some thought he
took and then took on d6 and then the
computer thought that there was a more
accurate move here but hey surprise
surprise you know with seconds left
before making time control of course he
just played a natural move and boom now
the computer thinks it's completely lost
work d8 correct the computer literally
thinks white is down by more than four
pawns you just look over losing the
piece straight just losing the piece
just losing the piece unfortunate for a
month yeah but that's what happens when
you get so low on time so low on time
and what was already a bad position
you're bound to end up missing something
yeah so in fact literally the computer
thinks white has nothing better than to
play a move like Queen III allow b4 and
then just give up one of the pieces so
obviously just over well we have a
request from you know YouTube chat to
take a look at your dihn's game why
don't we head over and see what's going
on there
yeah this is are we you're in one forest
okay min thank you it looks like it's
gone into a bishop and rook endgame here
this one should be a drop this one
should be a draw and and I think in fact
this one is so clearly should be a draw
wouldn't shock me if it was a greed draw
soon now if I had to take sides I'd
rather have block because block
certainly does well it looks like a mon
has resigned that position so hopefully
we get Dennis in for an interview
Oh that'd be great very nice game that'd
be great so coming back to this end game
I mean if I did have to choose sides I
would take block black has a little bit
more active pieces but basically
everything's happening on one side of
the board there's there's really no way
no serious way for a block to make
progress
this one fizzling out I physically no
okay well then what did you have in mind
for taking a look at next well I would
suggest we check in with the ax Kobe on
swears game that's where I was
interested in looking as well
yeah that's gotten pretty interesting
he's making quite a bit of progress it
looks like let's go back to where we had
started okay we just saw this move g5
from laughs yeah so remember only last
tuned in white had just moved the bishop
back to b3 right I see a black eyeing up
maybe the f4 square with this night but
you were mentioning that out y can
simply play g3 young that square off so
black played the Bishop to c6 white
played Queen a6 attacking this pawn
block defended and then white just move
the bishop back very simple chest they
should be five pushing the Queen back
moving the Queen back not not really
much happening but interestingly he
decided to push the pawn to f5 which
certainly looks like a
controversial choice the computer
doesn't like it I'm not so sure I like
it
but you know he's trying to get activity
white move the night to an active square
you can see how this night could easily
come to III at least hit the square here
with some chances maybe some weaknesses
here yeah five square as well taking
stars of that pin that's right so you
push up push the pawn to push the knight
the bishop back bishop d1 Queen c6 and
this is this is where we sit now now now
black has very little time left and
block has to make four more moves now it
is true that block has a double attack
going on on the one hand the Queen is
attacking this pawn on e4 on the other
hand the bishop is attacking this knight
on c4 that's all well and good but well
I started interrupt you here I'll let
you continue a looking at this position
but we actually have Dennis Kaye Drake
ready to come in for an interview so I'm
gonna swap out here and we'll get Dennis
in to talk about his game excellent so
if I can just keep talking about this
position for a minute while we get ready
for that interview so of course white
has to do something about these double
attacks but just cuz he has to do
something doesn't mean he necessarily
has to defend either one of these in
fact white has two very powerful moves
to consider and I'm sure Cobian is
considering them right now one
possibility is for white to push the
pawn to d5 so one possibility is for
white to push the pawn to d5 which turns
out to be potentially quite dangerous
because if black takes on d5 you play
Knight to e3
now this discovers the attack against
the Queen and also allows white to take
back this pawn on d5 with the knight or
with the
then going back the other possibility is
for white to move the Queen to e7
and this attacks the rook on d8 and
obviously incurs represents a pretty
powerful incursion into Bloxx position
yes black moved the work back to d7 but
then white moves the Queen to b4 and now
this Bishop is attacked and if you play
this Bishop takes Knight rook takes
Knight Queen takes pawn after Bishop
takes pawn here this rook on d7 turns
out to be attacked by the bishop on a4
so there's a lot for a Cobian to think
about in this very interesting position
or again his opponent has barely a
minute to make five six more means seven
more moves very complicated position
where black is under pressure
great all right well tell us about your
games very exciting there yeah well I
don't know like during the game I think
that I actually had like big big
problems during the game but then after
I play the move Bishop g6 I realize that
it's not so easy for white actually
because after you played Queen g2 which
move was that like 22 like when he 22nd
move I kind of had a feeling that I'm
very close like to be very like much
worse can we why don't we scroll through
the game quicker
yeah you can you can commentate for us
and show us where you think this so
basically like this line with E for I
always thought that it's nothing for
white but to be honest my only
experience in that line is from like
playing blitz games right right so there
I had no problems at all right but here
like in the game okay I played like this
like you take on e4 then you yeah he
takes back now we can play c6 for Bishop
e6 whatever mhm
in nigt Castle and I was thinking maybe
Queen EA to play because if I play now
Queen e8 instead of the a6 move white
cannot actually castle at all
mm-hm because if he can so think we need
five immediately and our g4 Bishop g4
and I g4 mate right so so just to show
what he's pointing out if Queen e8 yes
so actually even if castles King side we
need
Queen age 5 yes and now this H pawn is
attacked I mean yes he can play king h2
but I always say at least drove with 9g
for at least it looks a little passive
it looks a little yes and just to point
out to the viewers this would be
catastrophic because a Bishop takes pawn
pawn takes Bishop Knight takes pawn and
the computer is literally giving you me
as yes so we can't do that but I didn't
play that because I was thinking what if
it plays just I don't know like where f4
or G 4 I don't really I'm not really
sure do I want to put my Queen on the
King side right on because I was
thinking maybe like I'll go Queen b6
taking some pawns but there was actually
I wasn't sure like what is this okay I
played a6 does not want to push b5 so I
guess a force force and now you play a 5
I mean this is something like King's
Indian stuff sure we're good now they
were very good squares c5 and before but
it's not so simple still what did he
play no because all right yeah I played
Bishop d6 the tree and now I played 96
ok this all looks normal very normal
yeah
and now my plan with Knight ft7 I think
that is very bad mood because when I put
my knight on c5 from D then my mate when
he six is actually totally useless
yeah like next night before is never
doing anything and he just played a very
smart move ok f 490 c5 I know you played
rugby 1 a very I think smart move
because now I'm kind of like I don't
know I wasn't sure like what to play
because my knight on e6 is always very
very annoying for me so let's take a
look at so the we're letting sort of
stock fish you know do its thing here
and I know in this position you you
played Bishop f7 you play Bishop f7 here
but let's go back and take a look and so
what stock fish is recommending is Ponte
yes it was my idea
actually that's why I play Bishop e7
because and now it's a Ponte Bishop f6
okay he plays it immediately yeah okay
94 yeah well then I maybe go back with
the Bishop to d7 or one I think so yeah
or actually actually it likes just
defending the bishop no big deal to give
the bishop we have the bishop okay
yes actually like later on I realized I
have to take on f4 because I play just
like waiting rooms like Bishop f7 but
I'm not even sure
can you play maybe f5 when Bishop f7 I'm
not sure what's that position you mean
right here no no not here yeah like here
well like it's probably no problems
because I have a very good King scene in
it yeah I think that's right I think
it's a very nice position for from that
actually and it makes a lot of sense
because you're activating all your
pieces yes yes yes okay
this Queen e8 is also very nice move I
didn't realize that I can just give me
one squared bishop oh yeah so this was
the thing you wanted to hold the light
square bishop but maybe that was not the
right to say yes seven and no I was
thinking what if he the place at five
now said Oh Queen d2 is it possible
because my idea first was to go fish oh
yeah but then I wasn't sure what if it
just plays Queen d2 what is that
position like it looks like I'm just
getting a very good position but I
actually wasn't that sure yeah well
again we're letting stock fish crunch
and it does likewise position actually
it wants to keep the dark square bishop
which makes sense white has more space
right what I was thinking one Bishop f2
maybe then night before and things like
that I'm gonna not start jumping to d3
what is he doing okay maybe just 91 or
actually if we sort of let it crunch for
a minute it just wants to okay be show
me six can I go there now there may be
g4 actually yeah
then I have big big problems yeah okay
okay little Phantom activity yes yeah
and then meanwhile if the bishop has to
give up this diagonal you bring the
bishop out yeah yeah I mean yeah like
that's the thing actually and so
probably this might be night from f6 to
d7 was just I'm miss totally for me yeah
I mean if I take we need that for me
Utley then yet then it makes sense and
it's a very nice I guess position for
black but how I played it was I probably
probably just missed the whole idea so
probably the key idea is to take years
away I mean activate the PS not worry
about the two bishop I realized that
like this will actually play a bishop f7
because I didn't want to have maybe four
Tempe later on right there take but
actually I don't even want to put my
Bishop on next and probably the bishop
goes anyways right around to maybe seven
we're seeing right maybe some inaccuracy
so table it takes and you know to be
honest I mean stockfish still doesn't
think this is
whoops what's going on what yeah sorry
okay for some reason for some reason
it's okay Bishop it's civil yeah so II
takes a 4G takes a 427 I mean yeah like
I still don't think that I'm like maybe
not even worse at all maybe like
slightly worse but it's very I think
there is two like simple position for me
also to play yeah but here root kd8
I think he found a very interesting plan
this teenage - what did that play here I
played it very slowly I never liked a
bit you never liked Bishop f6 I don't
know why because I never you know like I
wasn't sure about it position Bishop f6
and then if he plays like rook do you
want Bishop before I mean if we exchange
those because normally that's very good
for black of course to exchange those
bishops but I wasn't sure how am I gonna
like defend without the black squared
Bishop to be here but it's interesting
because the way you ended up playing
Rick fe8 Bishop f3 and now the bishop
actually went back to FA and this is
actually that we're looking at the
computer evaluation this is the first
point where stockfish actually thinks
white has the advantage that's more than
just sort of background noise actually I
agree I agree that white is better
because I wasn't like do you see my
moves like what would you want King h8
I'm just trying to defend from the right
from the mating threats and then I mean
the whole idea it's sometimes to push d5
it's never so easy because he will just
take CD and CD he'll he says might be 5
we're taking the Queen and then e 5
alright and then always 94 and my knight
on a6 is terrible and so on so I think
if we play a few more moves well the
viewers will be able to see what you're
describing which is white seems to be
getting more active they actually
actually thought that lifer Bishop u6 I
took a lot of time like 2025 minutes
yeah and I actually thought that it's a
really good move if it if tactic doesn't
work here okay it says that five right
yes it does and what happens if I just
go back verse seven that was my idea
interesting all right so Babu
so let's just um yeah petrosian's to
believe have drawn their game and we'll
go and take a look at that in a minute
we'll just play this variation out
momentarily we're letting the computer
sort of crank its wheels for for a
minute it just sort of looks like a
little better for white yes okay but
more space more active yeah but now my
plan is very simple because now I can
always go 93 95 then put the next night
to on from a six to c5 now I go to
square 25 if he cannot attack me very
fast on g7 then I think I have no
problems like because here I was only
calculating or Knight h5 or Bishop d4
but on what moves always have some
tactics like emission before probably
just d5 also so that's why actually like
Bishop g6 here he also like didn't know
what to do he also explained a lot of
time here spent a lot of time here
playing Ruby yes he won and now I wasn't
sure should I just take home b3 tried
the very active thing you want this
looks like it was a clear mistake so
we'll come back to this move in a minute
let me see if I can go to the Petrosian
symbolic game so just want to point this
out to the viewers so this is a very
interesting game in the B groups it's a
sham Bullock had won all this games
previously let's just quickly scroll
through to where we had been we we
basically started here and the last
several moves went as follows rook t3
rookie five Queen B to King age six an
attempt to imbalance things but it
didn't really work out rook d4 g5 and it
looks like it's it's still maintaining
equality just barely rook e1 now
interestingly this this next move may
have been a mistake Queenie seven that
after Queen d2 and rook f8 the engines
are actually like they think White has a
very big advantage in this position and
yet for some reason they agreed to a
draw if we if we if we go back just a
couple of moves in this position
rather than Queenie 7 the move the
computer likes is Knight f4 certainly a
very logical move very active square for
the knight but just a cursory look shows
that this King is pretty walking the
plank so this King is actually believe
it or not this King is going to be
participating in some degree or another
in this in this attack but incredibly
black can play rook takes g5 okay the
idea is if rook takes f4 we have Queen
III check rook F 2 and now study like
rook d1 and the computer is telling us
that this position get ready for it is a
draw impossible for human beings
especially short of time to play moves
like was only more like 93 maybe you
know yes that's exactly right
although actually even Queen f6 check
works too oh okay but but instead we
have this position where it in fact it
turns out White has a very large
advantage and yet
Petrosyan was willing to agree to a draw
so very interesting development in the
tournament now let's get back to your
game so Dennis let's get back to your
game and we were at this point here
black had just played this move Bishop
to g6 and and in this move lots of
tension but white played a very big
mistake
played rook but1 no yeah like they can
put our lifes of course taking just the
phone might be three but his I think I
also saw earlier it says d5
I think the d5 is like much better
choice for me because he's like already
in five minutes
yes and he was thinking for twenty
minutes so if I take know like first of
all like I'm on IB three I'm a pawn up
but then he maybe has some attack right
why would you why would I risk that if I
can yell at the second choice is d fine
for black no or the first Perley yeah
he's gonna change yeah like DF I think
makes a lot of sense now because no I I
have the tactic after City five which I
think he has to do right
I have 93 so in this in this position
white did place he takes d4
and we're sure why it's not sorry I'm a
little I'm not expert with the OIC we
have to do it this way sorry about that
so just to just to scroll through this
quickly so we're at this critical d5
moment that Dennis played c65 93 be five
so so far the computers agreeing with
all the moves but as you pointed out a
very sort of difficult set of decisions
for what to make short of time
Knight takes rook takes 95 d6
Queen f7 still thinks that White has the
advantage but difficulty to play but in
this position actually with more thought
the computer thinks it's more equal if
white plays Bishop to e4 before but we
can leave that aside because let's just
show what happened Bishop takes e5 and
this is a clear mistake
now after Bishop takes Knight the
computer actually likes the position
interesting and green of Florence's in
this position this would have been even
stronger attacking the rook on c1 oh
wait oh okay I was thinking lady why
don't when I te to I just take one e5 or
one yes
92 Queen D 5 okay yeah yeah taking those
bones were actually was actually more
important I was looking for material
sorry about that I've lost the analysis
board I'm not sure why if so I guess
we'll just have to finish up in invoice
but but basically white made this
critical mistake short of time when
after Bishop takes on c5 suddenly you
have a very good position and you were
just able to press it there were there
any critical moments after that that you
thought really anything changed I mean
to be honest after after Bishop g6
through q1 d5 I already thought that
black is better now of course like the
commuter sees those tactics for for
white which I didn't like maybe they
were
some very precise way for white to still
save the position yeah but clearly you
are the one press yeah like to be honest
like I just thought that I'm like much
better about as it seems it's not like
that
yeah well and after the next move so
yeah here he just started blundering a
lot yes exactly so and understandable
very very tactical position very sort of
Tommy's on one minute basic yes exactly
so after after 91 and now you play
Bishop 83 actually the funny thing is
the computer and just like okay the pawn
I realize they're just taking those
points is much important right is like
it's probably just winning for black
very easily
those two rooks will be very very act
although ironically it's probably but
from a practical perspective it's
probably better to wait as long as
possible to take the pawn yeah but I can
can I just see like the end of like I
don't think that I'm interested in if it
if it works yeah so um unfortunately
we're having some technical problems
we're not able to show the board but I
think the point for the viewers is after
that transformation where you had you
you won the exchange yes white has these
connected pawns f45 d6 but your pieces
are very active and he and there may
have been a thin road for white to
travel to still maintain the balance but
probably impossible from a practical
perspective and then you were just able
to find the right time to take on d6 and
just smash White's position yeah I think
so too but I think that at the end like
Ruby 6 is a very important move yes
because if here's like I think four more
moves to play and he will get like 30
more minutes and it's not I mean that
material yeah those three pawns are very
very dangerous yeah I wasn't sure like
what's that position at all so but then
I saw rook d6 and I was thinking okay
this has to be winning in the end like
my idea was actually just to go for an
endgame where I'm Queen Bishop and four
pawns against Queen Knight and three
points it was my idea to get from that
position to there but his bones are
terrible it's always saying on b3 his
King is very bad yeah so like I wasn't
really afraid to go for that no but yeah
like after that it was it was I think a
good a good game congratulations well
done
thank you very much alright thank you
hi my name is Ryan Chester and I'm the
development manager for the Saint Louis
chess club I'm here to tell everyone
about a golden opportunity that we have
right now we're selling golden tickets
for $50 a piece it's a 50-50 raffle
$5,000 will go to the Scholastic chess
initiative for the st. Louis chess club
and $5,000 will go to a lucky winner
we're only selling 200 of these and
we've already sold many to grandmasters
and all of our commentary team as well
so if you're interested please call the
Chess Club or go to our website on the
homepage and buy a golden ticket there
thank you and good luck
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when you visit st. Louis you'll probably
want to watch the Cardinals or the Blues
what about after the game
heading back to the hotel would be a
major error instead boogie through the
city and discover the music that gave
the Blues their name at the National
Blues Museum Broadway Oyster Bar or even
the legendary Blueberry Hill so whether
you love the Cardinals the Blues or the
Blues come play with us you guys know I
can't play this right st. Lou is always
exploring welcome back to the fall chess
classic very interesting a raffle going
on that Ryan Chester introduced to you
guys there during the break be sure to
get your golden tickets now they are
going to be drawn on September 30th and
you do not have to be present to win so
no reason not to buy well that was a
very interesting interview from a
dentist there a very interesting game
that he there was a lot of depth to it
but what's going on in our remaining
games here Patrick well I think this a
really innocent game for us to take a
look at casada versus fear yeah and you
know when we last checked in we said
okay objectively it's probably not a big
advantage for block but black has a lot
of pressure can keep squeezing squeezing
squeezing probably should be drawn but
you know could go could go well could
could go against white and sure enough
in the space of just several moves look
what happened we sort of we started from
this position black repositioning the
knight yeah 96 interesting white making
a decision to try to trade that F pawn
off and now black choosing a very clever
maneuver just not taking that pawn on e4
that knight on e5 very well-placed
blocking that pawn on e4 meanwhile this
King on d4 has really broken through
become much more active now the computer
right now says hey hey no problem
everything's under control
but you know sometimes that just
requires people to humans to make very
difficult computer-like moves this is a
very interesting idea from black
removing the knight from the stellar
Square on d4 so that the King can can
advance further oh yeah I mean basically
swapping allowing that King to come
through with that night on e5 super
well-placed now I'll briefly show the
computer thought rook c2 was the right
move and I'll tell you why because after
rook be six it thinks we're Bishop d1
rook takes rook takes and it's it's
willing to think that this position is
and let's let's assume that the
computers right it generally is but have
to be very precise there have to be very
very precise what ended up happening
instead rook she was not so precise rook
b6 they should be one all those
naturally now interestingly black may
have had an even stronger move he chose
to play with before very very
understandable the computer in this
position actually thinks night d3 is
exceptionally strong and just hitting
the rook and yes and now if Brooke c4
check King III you really don't have to
worry about this extra pawn it isn't
going anywhere
look how far blocks pieces have
infiltrated and suddenly this King white
the white king here on h2 can find
itself in danger right now what ended up
happening instead is before yeah black
it's not really rushing here not rushing
still very pleasant position and now h4
and this looks like it was a pretty big
mistake
no yeah 93 even stronger now that Rick
see yes available yes that's exactly
right the problem is there's no good
square for this work to go to
it's basically deemed banished into the
corner of course there's there's the
classic rule
don't put your pawns in the same color
as your Bishop in these end games yes
and it's really really showing itself to
be true here also
I mean look just just look at this rook
and just to just to visually highlight
how blocked in it is but banished to the
corner yeah I mean all of White's pieces
are stepping they've they've almost
formed a geometric pattern of passivity
here whereas blacks king
penetrating in the night very strong the
rook not doing anything at the moment
but boy at some point it's gonna come
over and make itself felt this looks
like a very very painful position in
fact this position is so bad the
computer thinks block should take the
pawn on h4 look and it's a matter of
fact that's exactly what happened in the
game Wow
and now believe it or not the computer
thinks why shouldn't take the pawn back
that's how bad it is Thanks
yikes yeah so I think we are probably
looking I mean of course still still an
ongoing game anything can happen but I
would be putting my money on block to
win this that is huge news for the B
group if yessir wins this game he moves
into shared first place with a Jackson
booyaka I know he drew his game today
yes and I think that's actually a game
we should take a look at sure they drew
under very interesting circumstances yes
this was of course the game with that
strong EEP on that was moving up the
board yes no absolutely this is very so
what we have here is the final position
and the computer actually is quite
confident that this final position is
good for white let's scroll back a few
moves so here we are in this position
well we'll start here in this position
this is sort of like a roundabout the
last time we were checking in white
played rope d3 black played rookie 5 and
this is actually a perfectly good
position is it still roughly equal
dynamic balance if you will queen-to-be
to obviously makes a certain amount of
sense here pinning the rook to the king
and now a black played King h6 a very
bold move but still a move that doesn't
doesn't really lose the dynamic balance
sure rook to d4 obviously with the idea
of moving the rook over here to h4 so
black pushes the pawn to g5 to stop that
and white very understandably sorry very
understandably white pushes the pawn to
age for trying to try loose that King
black plays e 2 maintaining the dynamic
balance
here but now and and remember shambolic
was under time pressure here the
computer is quite confident that the
best move really the only good move in
this position is for black to play
Knight to f4
yeah very natural but also slightly
scary cuz it's very natural
but if pawn takes g5 of course you have
to take back with the King no but
actually but but actually you cannot
take back with the auto ok that's what
makes this so terrifying right in fact
after pawn takes pawn just to just to be
clear if black takes back with the King
white goes rook takes rook and it's over
ah yes because Queen Queens overloaded
yes
Queens overloaded so as we go back here
after pawn takes excuse me after pawn
takes pawn Chuck in fact black has to
play rook takes pawn
Wow just giving up the night yes you say
what but wait that can't be the right
move right as a matter of fact whites
only move is to take the knight but
that's not a hard move to find yeah
there's there's Queen e3 check there's
Queen e3 check and then rook f2 and now
the only move that block can play the
only move but it maintains the dynamic
thanks g2 no one okay rook do you want I
thought there might be some Perpetual
after it takes g2 in no no there is
after Brooke takes King takes there's no
perpetual I mean we can go back over it
if you want to see but there is no
perpetual no the only way the only way
is to play route d1 and now believe it
or not White has two moves a virtually
equal they both hold the draw white can
play the Queen to f6 check white can
move the knight to d3 either one holds
the draw right but without going into
the details the point that I'm making
here is in this position stem Bullock
had maybe a minute maybe less I don't
know to make to reach move forty it's
move thirty three his only move was to
play this incredible-looking
Knight f4 move but he didn't he played a
very natural move he played Queen e7 and
now after Queen e7 white played Queen d2
Computers very happy with this move
thinks Black has white has very large
advantage right rook f8 normal move
computer thinks it's good but
nevertheless white has very large
advantage and in this position they
shook hands agreed to a draw that's
insane
that's pretty it's pretty interesting
now when I look at this position I mean
I have the benefit that I'm actually
looking to what the computers recommend
right nevertheless this move here does
not look that hard for me to find Knight
e4 and just a piling on that Jeep on
piling on the Jeep on and of course the
key point here is you cannot play rook
takes Knight because if rook takes rook
and you cannot play Queen takes rook
because it's over baby love checkmate
the engine in fact literally has nothing
to say at that moment it's all over so
at this point after 94 maybe the best is
for black to play the King to g7 but now
White has a number of good moves
y can play Knight takes pawn on g5 y can
play rook takes pawn on e to the point
without getting into the details is
white has the advantage right there are
several ways to play and this is a this
is absolutely a position worth plane and
yet fortune favors the bold when you
have good when you have good form I
suppose when stamboli ik had sort of
walked the plank here and was just at
the moment when y could have really I'm
mixing metaphors when you turn the screw
instead agreed to a draw well very
interesting stuff well good news for
Jack is he maintains his very impressive
score with three and a half out of four
he now shares first place with the
anarchists out of Perez after that game
yes well in the closing minutes of our
show why don't we take a quick look back
at that Ray Robson game in that var game
before we close out yeah but you're not
keeping an eye on let's take a quick
look at the Ray Robson game this one has
has transformed in a very interesting
way now it doesn't take a grandmaster to
see that white probably has the
advantage right Hey look White has a
queen and hey look black doesn't but
let's go back and and actually just see
what happened here so way back when well
we're going a little bit farther sorry
so I believe the last time we checked
into this game it's been a while the
Queen was on f6 so what we'll get there
in a moment
whoops oh and sorry actually it so so
white made some very nice maneuvers over
gone Kings so so I just want to get back
to the point where White had the Queen
on it okay here we go so why get played
rook takes rook mm-hmm Queen takes now
you remember that what the computer
liked was moving this Knight here from a
far from c4 to a5 and a c6 right
very very logical but gray played
differently and I'd say also very
logically rook F wanted I'm just putting
more pressure putting more pressure move
d7 to defend okay Queen f3 White has an
extra pawn very pleasant position 28 so
some maneuvering ensued just sort of
moving the pieces around we're not gonna
get too bogged down on it basically so
white still has an extra pawn not a
whole lot is happening here or maybe
actually things are happening but not go
into the details yeah and now it's
coming up in a minute
white maneuvers is Knight over here to
set up for this check and black plays
Knight c5 and this actually turns out to
be allow white to trade Queens very
advantageous Lee now in fact the
computer says that black should have
Luther King either to h7 or to GA White
has a very large advantage because in
either case why it's gonna be able to
take this pawn on d6 and blocks not
gonna be able to take back because
there's either going to be Queen h4 shot
fall by Ruby 8 or Ruby a check fall by
Queen h4 and right
however after King f8 Queen h4 turned
out to be a monster because actually
cannot capture that you cannot capture
this Queen because rook b8 yeah very
nice checkmate yes
so instead after Queen h4 black had to
move the King over
to e8 and now of a very basic very
powerful tactic believe it or not the
computer thinks isn't even stronger move
in this position but I'll leave you at
home to figure out what it is that turns
out that there's an even better way to
win this position but rook b8 six point
six five pawns for white the computer is
perfectly happy with this
that'll doing take that will do queen H
a king d7 Queen takes Queen pawn takes
Knight and now White's turned to move
not very hard to find the move the
computer thinks it's best which is pawn
takes pawn and this King is which is in
very very good rate played and so here
we are white has one two three four five
pawns black has three what has Queen
versus rook at night it's just a
devastating material advantage it may
take a little time to break through the
last desperate blockade that block has
thrown up but I think it's pretty safe
to say this game is going to be one zero
and very very quickly let's take a quick
look at vars game I think he's still
doing quite well he's advanced the pawns
quite far up the board so that b VAR a
KO being against doris where it's up in
Group A oh sorry yeah and then uh and
then we will do our closing remarks ah
so far yes not used to using this
version of course solution so yeah Wow
so a lot has happened here very very
good position for white what do we think
about the current position well the
current position we think is winning for
white so let's go yeah and yes sir
Quezada Perez is actually officially won
his game so he does in fact move into
joint first place Wow congratulations
congratulations so as we look at this a
Cobian game so black has taken the
bishop white has taken the night and now
if we just quickly count material white
obviously same number of minor pieces
same number of rooks black has three
pawns white has four white has an extra
pawn in addition to having an extra pawn
black's pawn structure is well it's a
little bit on the shattered side and
more to the point white is going to have
two connected pawns once somehow or
other there's a this F pawn joins
White's epon here very very strong
position for for widen definitely
expecting a win here definitely
expecting a win
well with that last look around the
table why don't we take a look at the
results we've had so far today in the a
group it's been an interesting one so
far ray Robson is still playing it's
Ilyas myrin but of course he's up a
queen for a rook and a knight and we're
expecting him to win that game without
too much difficulty
Alex epitaphs drew against the other
Alex in the in the a group Alexander
Linderman front malcolm you drew his
game it's your turn more forest that's
what we expected olexander port nick is
still playing against of a thief dura
bali and they have a very tight game
going on still very unclear what's going
on there but you'll have to follow that
your for yourself on us chess champs
after we get out of here and lastly in
our key matchup of the day Varro Cobian
seems to be doing it again against our o
spirits var of course won this matchup
two years ago in the spring chess
classic and he seems to be winning again
today and where does that leave us in
the a group well it leaves us in a very
interesting position it seems as though
the Cedar Valley needs only to draw his
game to maintain his position in clear
first place and following close behind
him will be Alexander Linderman and a
version manages to win his game he will
also be tied for second place following
the tournament leader Massif dura bali
and now let's take a look at the B group
Steven Zurich is still playing against
victory medal left ski that game is
looking to be a drawn rock n des Mille
them a B black is you know on the better
end of that Aman Hamilton lost his game
to Denis K Drake who came in here and
gave a very interesting interview I was
a very interesting game very deep game a
lot going on there and as we just stated
alexander fear lost to yes or quesada
perez and abet occur Corian drew with a
rhombic Obion and in our key matchup of
the day minimal petrosyan actually gave
Jackson Billy AK a draw in a position
where possibly he really could have and
should have played for more yeah he had
quite a nice advantage yes
and in the B group this leaves us with
two leaders in yes sir Quezada Perez and
Jackson buyuk both with a very
impressive score of three and a half out
of four so that leaves us for today
tomorrow is definitely going to be an
interesting round the soul leaders are
in the a group maintaining his position
and in the beat group Jack actually does
not get it done today and he has been
caught by a circus out of Perez to be
interesting to see what these players do
tomorrow absolutely fantastic chess so
tune in
we'll see we'll have some more great
matchups for you thanks for watching
yeah we'll be here tomorrow at 3:30 p.m.
for more coverage of the 2019 ball chest
classic this has been a presentation of
the st. Louis chess club
you